quand j'ai commencé ma vie publique
il y a 12 ans, j'ai compris que
les médias pourraient être intéressés par ce que je
faisais,
mais je ne savais pas à quel point
cette attention deviendrait accablante,
c'est une fascination mondiale pour Diana
parce qu'il n'y a jamais eu quelqu'un comme
elle avant
et il n'y a jamais eu  quelqu'un comme elle
depuis et
je pense que les gens sont fascinés par l'
énigme de cette femme
[Musique]
douce petite enfant c'est un peu un garçon
manqué elle n'aimait pas
se déguiser j'ai dû l'emmener à une
fête d'anniversaire une fois quand la nounou était
partie  et je n'ai pas pu lui mettre une robe
[Musique]
qu'avez-vous pensé quelle a été votre
impression instantanée à tous les deux de quoi
parlez-vous je me souviens avoir
pensé qu'elle était une
jeune fille de 16 ans très joyeuse et amusante et attirante
et je veux dire super  amusant et fantaisiste et plein
de vie et tout
et euh je ne sais pas ce que vous pensiez de
moi c'était
assez incroyable
et comment était-elle avec eux, elle était toujours
heureuse et sociable a montré un grand sens
de l'humour
et était très détendue avec les enfants
[Musique]
et je suis étonné qu'elle ait été
assez courageuse pour m'affronter
et je suppose qu'en amour, bien sûr,
tout ce qui est amoureux signifie votre propre
interprétation de [Musique]
les troubles de l'alimentation, que ce soit
l'anorexie ou la boulimie,
montrent comment un individu peut transformer
le  nourrir le corps en une
attaque douloureuse contre eux-mêmes
[Musique]
les câlins n'ont pas d'effets secondaires nocifs
si nous jouons tous notre rôle
pour que nos enfants se sentent valorisés,
le résultat sera formidable
en tant que mère de deux petits garçons, je pense que nous
devrons peut-être trouver  un moyen sûr d'aider
nos enfants
à les nourrir et à les préparer à affronter la vie
en tant
qu'adultes stables et confiants.
avoir un impact cela
faisait une différence
[Musique]
le vih ne rend pas les gens dangereux à
connaître
donc vous pouvez leur serrer la main et
leur faire un câlin
le ciel sait qu'ils en ont besoin
diana remarquablement calme
dit euh à camilla
regarde ne me traite pas comme un  idiot je
sais ce qui se passe.  maintenant que je savais
à ce stade particulier
qu'il n'y avait qu'une seule direction et que
c'était le divorce,
je pense que l'intention était vraiment juste d'
essayer de raconter son histoire
afin que le monde puisse comprendre la
vraie diana
parce que rappelez-vous avant la sortie du livre,
elle vient d'être vue  comme ce
portemanteau plutôt sage et silencieux cette parure
attrayante pour le prince charles
et elle voulait vraiment raconter
sa version de l'histoire
que de toutes les ironies à propos de diana
peut-être la plus grande était-ce
une fille qui portait le nom de l'ancienne
déesse de la chasse
était en  la fin la personne la plus traquée de
l'ère moderne
je ne suis pas une personnalité politique je suis une
personnalité humanitaire
et j'ai toujours été et serai toujours
[Musique]
je dirais que j'ai toujours cru que la
presse finirait par la tuer
mais pas  même je pourrais imaginer qu'ils
prendraient une main aussi directe dans sa
mort,
comme cela semble être le cas, il semblerait
que chaque propriétaire et éditeur
de chaque publication qui a payé pour
des photographies intrusives et exploitantes
d'elle
encourageant des individus avides et impitoyables
à tout risquer  à la
poursuite de l'image de diana
a du sang sur les mains aujourd'hui
tu